Hey, I'm Sterling Tadlock, and I'm from
North Carolina, and I was adopted after birth.
>> I'm Ryan Salvador, I'm from Maryland, and I'm lactose intolerant.
>> I'm Carol Kushnir, I'm from Woodside, California, and I had the BROCA two
mutation. Which predisposes me to the possibility of breast or ovarian cancer.
>> I
am Kagure Kabue, I'm from Kenya and I have dark skin,skin
pigmentation as well as being preliminary that has a high frequency of sickle
cell. I am Ginny Foos originally from Boston, but now from the
Bay area. I have achondroplasia which is the most common form dwarfism.
>> Great thank you so much for being here you know,
as we go throughout the course we are going to talk a lot
about in depth the biology of the traits that you
guys are here to represent for us. We are going
to teach gene regulation. We're going to teach inheritance patterns and
dominance. We're going to teach about mutations and complex traits, as well
as how to trace our lineage and family ancestry. and
as we get on this journey to do this, it's
probably a good idea for us to maybe better define
the traits that we have. And that's not an easy process.
Sometimes we have traits and, we may think they fit neatly
in certain categories, but then we start thinking about them in
different ways. And we think it's not so simple anymore. So,
for anyone who's interested, I want you to sort of take
the trait that you're sort of here to talk to us
about in this course. And I want you to try to
tell me, first if you think your trait is visible or
hidden, and then physical or behavioral, and then innate or learned.
And let's start with Jenny over here. What do you
think about that? Do you think you're what's a what's a
[CROSSTALK]
>> I think my trait is visual, visible.
>>
[LAUGH]
Visible, huh?
>> Visible, yes. I think that my, it, it's a physical issue. And at
times an emotional issue. and I think it has shaped who I am, in a good way.
>> Absolutely. Kugaray, what do you think? Tell us about let's focus on
skin pigmentation. Would you classify that as a visible or a hidden trait?
>> Visible.
>> Visible,
in general.
>> Yes, a visible trait
[UNKNOWN]
Physical or behavioral?
>> Physical.
>> And innate or learned?
>> It's innate.
>> Innate. Right.
[CROSSTALK]
So, pretty, that's more of a, I guess, more of
a straightforward kind of like, achondroplasia and dwarfism. You know,
they sort of fit into more easily defined categories. Carol,
tell us a little bit about a BRCA 2 mutation.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Well, BRCA2 mutation is invisible, and I
didn't know I had BRCA2 mutation. And I, it's invisible.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And I did take steps once I found out. Took,
I took steps to address
the issue.
>> Mm-hm. Are there any would you describe, obviously this seems
to be an innate trait, right? It's not anything you could change.
>> Right.
>> And and is most likely a
physical trait. And it manifests physically, not behaviorally.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Right.
>> In any real way.
>> It could manifest, basically.
>> It could. Exactly.
>> Right now, it doesn't.
>> Right, so it's sort of a little unclear, like,
whether or not it will have an effect or it won't.
>> Right.
>> All right. Ryan, what about lactose intolerance?
>> So in terms of visibility, that's a little trickier
because it's not, you can't tell by looking at me that
it, that I'm lactose intolerant. But if you watch me, you
can, you can tell, kind of by my choices that I make
while I'm eating. If I'm at a restaurant with friends,
then you might be able to see, why aren't you eating
that pizza. Or why are you taking a pill while
you're eating your food. So that sense it's visible and hidden.
>> Hm.
>> But it's definitely.
>> What about physical or behavioral as sort of the.
>> Yeah, that's the same thing. So it's. Definitely the trait itself
is physical, but it can manifest beha, it, it changes your behavior.
>> Very interesting. And this is something learned or innate?
>> it's definitely innate, but you learn that you have it.
>>
[LAUGH]
Exactly. And Sterling, what about adoption, that's
sort of a tricky kind of trait.
>>
[LAUGH]
Wow, it, it's hard to define that as as a trait, because I have a whole host of
traits that are all physical, hidden, innate, learned
they fall into both categories, from all the traits that
I have, I just don't know. You know my biological
relatives, if they also had those traits and what, how
their genetics contributed to the traits that I'm now expressing.